foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
check one two one two one two and three
how's everybody doing welcome in welcome
in welcome in
Sinjin witty eggplants Elwyn Draco
Alicia moonlace
doo-wop guy Mia
and Christy getting us started early
welcoming guys welcome in
good to see everyone here I think the
mic hold on I'm gonna turn the mic down
just a bit here
I think it's just a little bit too loud
check check let's go down to about
check check check check check
one two one two I think that's got it
I think that's good right there
2 A.M oh my goodness
good morning to you
good morning to you good morning good
morning
good afternoon good evening
depending on where you are in the world
people love the internet
Metro raconteur here just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell
and Welcome to our first ever
I'm calling it try wizard Tuesday I
don't know why I'd never coined at that
before because we used to always stream
here on Tuesdays
try wizard Tuesday people of the
Internet it's just more fitting now that
we can actually have like a dueling
tournament to go with it
all the way from the Netherlands no way
and by the way thank you to I think it
was low megahertz with the eight months
that had to be somebody changing their
name because I do not remember anyone
with that name
low megahertz thank you for the eight
months being a member also Christy with
the 10 months
another month of wonderful people and a
lovely Community Christy thank you so
much thank you for being here
thank you for stopping by to say hello
wild you love the vids hey thank you so
much appreciate it
Jenny in the house so we also have uh
Moon lace becoming a member of House
rack and tour
let's go moonlace all right here's how
we're gonna start the stream though
watch this watch this watch this
watch this dude
I still feel like the mic
I still feel like the mic is too loud
what do you think Christy you stream a
lot let me know is check check check are
we too loud I don't want to be peeking
is the volume peaking peeking peaking
I don't want to be peeking any I see it
hitting red I normally hit red that much
watch this here's how we're gonna start
the stream I'm gonna get I've got two
red keys
we're gonna get obscurious right here
right here off the Jump first key
we're not even gonna need a second key
watch this
I meant the second key this key right
here the game the game didn't this this
key
this key right here is going to be
obscurious
dang it
oh
I don't have any more I mean I need to
get more
oh wait purchasable with gems
how else do you do it how else do you
get red keys
sounds okay note turn it down a tiny bit
okay
yeah I just keep I'm hitting red way
more than I normally do and I've been
kind of tweaking
I don't know why I tweak these settings
like once I get something working
okay let's turn that down just a wee bit
and yeah let's take you down to five
right there check check check check
check one two check one two
a tournament that's what we're doing
that's what we're here for wild
that's what we're here for
Ginny you did 15 with no obscurus no way
oh my goodness
so what are there any other ways to get
the red keys right now I don't think
there are
uh uh for 900 dude for 900 I could get
and I have one thousand two forty six
I'll think about it I'll think about it
I thought I already accepted that Dylan
that's weird
you got it after 30 Keys the mat that's
the max right just buying them yeah
that's what I was thinking I know you
can get them from them oh wait what's
this what's this
what is this
Loyalty Rewards make in-game purchases
during the event to accumulate points
for bounce four oh yeah yeah
I heard it cost quite a bit though if
you want to get all the way to the top
so wait what is this three thousand
oh no do we have another new currency
what is this 3280
is that oh it's those things yeah
yeah those things
oh look at dealing with that one year
badge
used a hundred oh my gosh Draco
you used 110 keys and it got to 11. oh
wow
yeah since they don't have like the
bonus red keys I don't know I might have
to use some gems later
we'll see
we shall see but first I want to get
this dueling tournament going man I
think I'm just gonna
all right we should uh we should
probably do
let me see here
I'm trying to think of the best way I
know on James's stream the other day
might be a good idea to do a poll first
I want to get an idea of how many people
are gonna be joining
let's see here
go live
so we'll just do a little poll
and if you guys are going to participate
in the tournament
then just vote in this poll here
all right so let's see start a poll
do you want to play in the tourney so
here's some some rules here
yes or no ask your community
and I'll just get a head count there
before I make the room so we know
exactly how many people if I need to
make it what size I need to make it so
we're going to be doing solo
house
get in the Stream
um we're gonna be doing solos
we're going to be doing no bands
no bands at least at the start
everything's on everything is on the
table you can use any Echoes you can use
any cards you want I will have balanced
mode enabled though
you did get the time Turner thing though
nice the the skin
that's pretty cool at first I didn't
when I first saw they had skin it's like
what are they talking about with skins I
don't understand this
and then I figured it out it actually
applies to the the moves
[Music]
oh no I just realized it doesn't tell me
exactly
I'll have to do math to uh to calculate
it so guys if you're just if you're just
trickling in we have not started the
tournament yet go ahead and vote in the
poll right now I want to get a head
count here for how many people are going
to participate
I may play I may sit out depends on the
number
if we need like one more then I will
play but I kind of just want to
commentate everything honestly
you'll be home in an hour sounds good
Jenny we'll probably still be going for
sure
Christy you want to but you're you're
moving it a couple days no way
you're moving again
not like to a new city or state right
witty eggplants in very nice
okay I wish it would tell me the number
of votes instead of percent
all right so right now we have let's see
we have 10 people who have said they're
in
10 people are in
that's good that's perfectly uh nice and
even number
all right hold on 62 percent
yeah still at 10 I believe I believe
we're at 10 here
all right so we're just going to do
an elimination match room
and we will call it see if we have
enough room for tri-wizard
Tuesday
confirm oh no we don't just short
here let's change it to Retro
Oh that's oh it fits up here but then it
doesn't show down there
all right so we're gonna do like I said
solos balance mode will be enabled
detailed settings so we're not Banning
any Echoes we're not going to ban any
cards map selection oh let's see here
room of requirements pretty cool
oh let's do the high tower I'm going to
say the high tower
all right we're up to 17 votes okay 17
votes and 65. 65 times 17. okay that's
11 people all right we need five more
then if we could get five more that
would take us up to 16. otherwise we can
do one to start with eight
and I guess is it single elimination I
thought I remember seeing
solo elimination match rules
elimination matches allow multiple
players to participate at the same time
right right and this format players face
off against each other and a duel and
the loser is eliminated half of the
players are eliminated each round until
a final Champion emerges MP region speed
increase is 90 seconds into a duel
player health will gradually start
to decrease three minutes into a duel
the winner automatically enters the next
round
until the final Champion is decided the
defeated can stay in the room to watch
the battle
so we're not doing Duos
in duo in Duo duels yeah we're not doing
Duos
position display if the creator of the
room turns on the location permission
the room will appear in the location of
the creator
if the Creator does not turn on
positioning the room will randomly
appear in any position what
what does that even mean
somebody Sinjin you already got your
obscures to level 11 no way
you bought the offer with the free to
play gyms and didn't get it oh my
goodness Mia that's so unfortunate
paid season pass in the shop bundles guy
that's what I was thinking yes
ban the newest card
it's too early for that nah nah at least
I want to do at least one tournament
with everything on
one tournament with everything on
you can get them through the season
events
I remember they did a special like when
the game first launched but if you've
already done those you can't get any
more though can you
King of the North welcome in by the way
Roger what's up
good to see you Roger
oh yeah let me look at the poll again oh
we're at 20 votes now hold on hold on
20 votes
no not divided by
well we got 12. okay we got 12 people
right now
why can't we just I wish we could just
do
so we need four more people guys
four more don't worry this is no
pressure
low stay
Don't Be Afraid come on in the water the
water is warm it's fine
it's all fine if not I'll give it let's
see it's 8 18 my time right now if we
don't have enough by 8 20. we'll go
ahead and start it with eight and just
like first come first served the first
eight to get in there we'll do it
King in the north right now we just need
you to vote in the YouTube poll I
haven't even set up the room just yet
I haven't set up the room yet I want to
get an idea of head count here before I
I choose the number here
allow spectating and push to channel uh
sure yeah
select push and once the room is open
the notification will be pushed to the
channel interested players can join the
room directly selecting no push
oh yeah I don't think we want to push it
because we're we have everybody here
no pressure it's not like the entire
tournament and stream was explode into
disaster
now we could always just play I could
play Duo games
we can do Grand Master duels if I have
to but no we got it we got enough people
interested
but if we can do the max one here I'd
like to do it
eating a late lunch early dinner at the
moment you'll try to join afterward
haven't been on the game today yet
there's a big pretty significant update
today Roger new card it's pretty cool
I've had it used on me a couple of times
but I haven't used it
myself yet because I don't have it I had
two red keys left over from last time
use them and then didn't get it
you know you can always start in the
room yeah but if I if I start it then we
don't get enough
if we're short of 16. see I watched this
and expecto ghost stream yesterday
because somebody in the chat was like oh
if you have even numbers you can start
it
nope it didn't work that way
the new card is obscurus it is a dark
card
all right we're still at 20. so I'm
gonna go ahead and start with eight and
it's just gonna be first come first
serve to get in here so here's how you
get in guys
you're gonna search for the name retro
raconteur
which it should pop up over here if
you're in Opel I should pop up on the
left
let me show you the room info here so
there it is retro raconteur now here's
the key guys once you get in here this
does not mean you're in
so once you get in right here you need
to look in the bottom right corner over
here there's this little icon
so you click that icon right there and
then you're not gonna you don't want to
be in the viewers you want to be in the
teams
not in the viewers in the teams is where
you want to be so you have to click on
teams and then hit join
so like I'm gonna go over here and hit
viewers and I'm gonna join to a
spectator so Brooke you got in Brooke
you're officially the first one in
welcome in Brooke by the way good to
have you here
we don't have a location region selected
for our group which means we don't get
to use the top team tag
oh how do I do that Draco I need to do
that before the uh
before the stream Ends Tonight
I need to go in and do that
because Dylan did make me the captain
now he figured out how to do that
Ryan De La Cruz welcome in Ryan I know
you've been playing a lot of this hop in
here so everybody that voted in the poll
we had a bunch of you who voted in the
poll
go ahead and hop in we got Draco Brooke
swamp witch this one is only open to
eight people and we can also have
spectators so if you want to hop in and
watch you can do that as well now I will
actually I'm going to be spectating
so I'm just gonna pick
a different uh match to watch each time
and then of course we'll watch we'll
watch the end
but yeah so once you get into the room
guys looks like we've got we've got
quite a few here right now
we've got two four six seven nice so
there we go that's eight we got giant
stranger Mario's Twigs guy Khaleesi
swamp which Draco and Brooke Snape oh
dude I'm so pumped for this because I
know a lot of these players I've played
with several of them and they are pretty
talented
pretty talented players right here this
is gonna be fun all right so if you guys
still want to join the room you can and
you can just join me here as one of the
viewers Richard you're in as a viewer
welcome
so guys if you're in the tourney I'll
give you a minute or two here to make
sure you have your deck set up
nothing is banned everything is on the
table at least for this first tournament
we we might tweak it throughout the
night and change some things as we go
go to our team area yeah I'll I need to
do that Draco I'm actually going to
write that
right now
Leave myself a little note for it all
right so I guess I need to hit remind to
get ready
okay so oh wow there's several who
aren't ready all right so yeah whenever
you guys who are in The Duel
so here are the people that are dueling
Brook Draco swamp witch Khaleesi and
this is not necessarily who you'll be
matched up with Twigs guy Mario's and
giant stranger you guys are the duelers
you want to make sure you click ready
here in the bottom right corner
click ready in the bottom right corner
and we'll be good to go guys if you're
just tuning in for the first time
tonight welcome in you are watching try
wizard Tuesday this is our first ever
Harry Potter magic Awakening tournament
first ever magic awakened tournament
well if I did 16 uh eggplant we wouldn't
be able to start because we didn't have
enough
but we'll do another one don't worry
we're gonna be doing plenty
all right let's hit remind to get ready
okay swamp which and one otherwise it's
just like calling swamp which out right
there
it doesn't tell me the other person
that's so funny wizard Harry
you're a wizard Harry
yo who was that
all right I'm gonna go ahead and close
the poll
Channel Jacob
oh wait Jacob welcome to the channel
I don't know why I said Channel Jacob
Jacob thanks so much for subscribing
appreciate it
oh here we go dude we're ready we're
ready we're ready all right so I gotta
figure out how I want to make sure that
I can spectate
Okay match up list
all right how do I oh my gosh Draco and
Guy first round those are two of the
most experienced players right there
Mario's and twigs Brook and swamp witch
giant stranger and Khaleesi guys how do
I how do I spectate
how do I spectate
room ends wait oh wait open to spectator
here we go oh we gotta I want to watch
guy and Draco right here
oh my goodness these are the two of the
most experienced players that I know of
so and we can oh this is so cool how you
can switch between
all right so we're on we're watching
Draco we're seeing draco's cards right
now
guy started oh both running the
Bellatrix deck no surprise right there
we got an atmosphere charm going and
Pier totem locomotor so guy on the
offensive early here and our boy Draco
on the defensive but there's obscurus
there's the new card they both throw it
out at the same time Draco definitely
got the better of that scenario right
there
Draco very very close to getting a Death
Eater out as well gotta keep an eye on
that guy already having to bring Ivy out
we got the bombtastic bombs going Draco
on the defensive again but boy did he
weather that first storm incredibly well
and also guy already having to call out
a companion
and we can see who draco's got waiting
in the wings which guy by the way if you
guys are playing yeah they're not going
to be able to watch the stream at the
same time Death Eater on the field
oh wait I think Draco must have used a
companion as well and maybe I missed it
got an inflatus there guy getting the
Pixies out which is a really smart move
against the Death Eaters because it's
gonna distract them and the Death Eaters
they're not very smart man there's
another obscurus just-wing guy gets his
Death Eater and it completely takes him
out we have Ron on the field now
two runs on the field
big hit right there for guy okay look at
that exchange ladies and Gentlemen Just
a total reversal
guy now with a significant Advantage
here
over Draco but look at that meter for
Draco once again building up to the
Death Eater this time he's gonna get two
but will he survive to get the Death
Eaters out I do not know
yes he does
oh man staring right in the face of the
pure totem locomotors and the Death
Eaters they do their job even though
they are almost dead they do take care
of the locomotives for him
yeah this is gonna be tough for Draco to
pull back here
hits him with the obscurus that was a
good move right there but now guy has
two Death Eaters on the field Draco with
only 30 health and that's gonna be it
guy with a nice comeback right there to
take the first game from Draco oh my
gosh that was so intense we also got to
see the new card both of those players
use a new card right there Gigi's to
both I knew that was going to be a good
one those are two of the most
experienced players that I know
well done guys well done let's see who
else is moving on here
and we still have oh wait oh wait is
this match still going on I think this
one is still going can we sneak in there
to see the end of it
these two are still going on Brook Snape
and swamp witch see if we can catch the
end swamp which I think that is swamp
which I'm pretty sure
yes swamp Witch moving on right there
dude that must have been an epic one if
it was still going
no way so we do still get to see the
stats right there
all right okay so match-up list guys if
you if you got beat out stick around
we're gonna be doing a lot of these
tournaments tonight if you're here and
you're not in don't worry don't worry
because we're going to be doing plenty
more of these
all right so let's see we got swamp
which versus giant stranger and we have
Mario versus guy I'm gonna hop over and
watch uh swamp witch and giant stranger
this time
well dude we got a bunch of Spectators
in here now let's go
all right so we're gonna watch this uh
giant stranger versus swamp witch
stranger is another one who has been uh
playing a lot well all these people are
playing a lot everybody everybody is
participating in this tournament
has been playing a lot dude how do I
like switch I gotta figure out these
controls here man
again dude the common theme tonight lots
of Bellatrix no surprise that's who I
like to run as well so swamp which
getting things started early with the
monster book Stranger
has Cassandra over there in the corner
a confringo early right there
swamp which with a Cassandra as well two
very similar decks right here giant
stranger gonna go ahead and finish off
Cassandra there while giant strangers
Cassandra still up with a couple of just
a little bit of a monster book left or
not a monster book but a bombtastic bomb
swamp which is going with a little
protego diabolica
all the while trying to move away from
that atmospheric charm
you should do I should duel you for
Giggles witty eggplant man I wouldn't
want to embarrass you on stream
I wouldn't want you to be embarrassed
like that
trust me you wouldn't you wouldn't like
how it would end
I could talk I could talk a big game too
witty eggplant
I could talk a big game too
King of the North wait who are you in
the game
all right so giant stranger now with two
or no we've got two Death Eaters facing
off against each other swamp which has
one and so does stranger
stranger also has Ivy still on the field
as well and stranger playing a very
aggressive style staying up close to the
line where a swamp witch playing a
little more back
getting the niffler out and stranger
said nah nah I'm not gonna let you have
the niffler I'm sorry
just not gonna happen
and also Jacob you're asking for full
screen do you really want to take it
full screen if I take it full screen
then I have to put the webcam somewhere
and I feel like with this game you want
to be able to see like all of the
sections I mean we can go full screen
but I guess I would have to put myself
in like I don't know top left corner or
something I just always feel like the
webcam is blocking something whenever
you have this game full screen
but I'm open to try all right so
stranger has a pretty good Advantage
here right now
swamp what's just trying to weather the
storm with Hagrid which gives a little
bit of extra defense
as well as some maneuverability right
there
so Hagrid is gone but this is going to
spawn two Death Eaters this time for
swamp witch
stranger also trying to deal with the
Monster books all right this could be a
situation for swamp which to turn things
around Death Eaters still on the field
right there doing big damage to stranger
are you kidding me right now
swamp which completely turns the fight
around but stranger is also very close
to getting their own Death Eater there
they are that's gonna be two Death
Eaters spawning out for stranger plus
he's got the cats coming in too
swamp witch using what's that wait was
that uh
oh my goodness side along was that side
along Apparition there's a well well
placed incendio this match is dead even
anybody could win this anybody could win
this stranger getting hit by the
lightning bolts right now swamp which at
285 a dead feeder right in front of her
are you kidding me
you guys this game makes me hyped if you
can't tell
Ash dude
stranger Moving on but an epic epic
battle let's see if the other game is
finished yet now that I know we can hop
in I want to make sure that I let's see
is the other one still going guy moving
on
dude this is so cool man well played by
both of you right there stranger at
swamp which that was intense
such an intense game right there
all right guys if you're just joining
into the stream stick around we're going
to be doing another tournament here
momentarily
and if we have enough people we're going
to be opening it up to 16 this time we
only did eight
all right here we go the final battle
Guy versus stranger
and this isn't too big of a surprise
both of these players I know have been
playing the game for a while
and let's see if they're both still
sticking with the Bellatrix decks
where do you find the tournament to be a
spectator so L when you go into the
duels
and there's a little icon I think it's
the one at the top left
and it's the name of the room is just
retro raconteur all one one word no
spaces so guy again going on the
defensive early using Ivy to take away
the Cassandra that is big
very big stranger gotta put Cassandra
back just a little bit further
so that Ivy can't just sneak in right
there and take her away trust me I've
learned that the hard way I know
I know
even then though sometimes people use
Akio to pull Cassandra up or use like
esposo to bounce her so then ivy can
take her out all right can fringo right
there trying to get giant stranger out
of the trouble
Ivy is now off the field unfortunately
for stranger now there's a Death Eater
on the field
a Death Eater plus pure totem locomotor
you do you do not want to see that that
site right there is something you do not
want to be faced with
stranger just trying to survive right
now knows that they have to get rid of
the Bombs over there oh man oh man this
this could be trouble I be taking away
Ron though okay
here we go here we go guys if stranger's
gonna turn it around this is the moment
right here ivy on the field Death Eater
on the field Pixies on the field
unfortunately they're all grouped
together
unfortunately man the Death Eaters guys
they're powerful but they're not very
smart
they're not very smart so guy able to
take them out with an easy easy incendio
they're all grouped up together right
there
here comes the locomotors again another
confringo nice move right there but it
is just wow look at that man just not
doing enough to the locomotors
such a strong card right now the
locomotors are just so tough to deal
with and you can see guy is about to get
another Death Eater it's gonna be really
difficult for stranger to turn this one
around getting hit by the crucio right
now from the Death Eater but he brings
Ron out Ron is now on the field
the Death Eaters do amazing things
they just immediately melt
Ron
stranger now getting two Death Eaters on
the field but only one on one Health can
stranger hold off long enough no
very well played though by guy right
there what a match guy moves on
as our first Victor very well played I
don't know what wait I've never seen
this before
what is going on here is there is is
this guy supposed to be in the picture
I think we're supposed to be seeing guy
right there but we don't
guy GG's nicely done nicely done
all right let's do it again
let's do it again shall we
all right so what I'm gonna do
let's see how many people how many
people do we have
all right we got 45 people watching
right now
and we have 34 votes let's see
34 votes of people saying that they want
to guys if you're watching the stream
and you haven't voted yet let me know in
that poll right now
if you want to play
51 times 35 oh I think we have enough
I think we have exactly 18.
so I'm gonna back out
I'm gonna close out of this room here
and we're gonna make a new room for 18
or uh what was it 16.
all right hold on can I delete this one
now
yeah let's click here
oh wait or can we just change it right
here oh we can just change it
what is going on here
it's not letting me change anything
maybe I need to delete this one
oh yeah because there's still people in
there
maybe I have to go actually back inside
to do to remove it
yeah great great first game guys
first game with Draco should make
YouTube videos so close it was a good
one
it was a good one
why can't I just delete this you guys
and start a new one
maybe I have to delete it from inside
which is kind of strange
wait King of the North did you which one
are you in the tourney
the room info Maybe
I wish it would just let you change it
right there
yeah that's I'm trying to just delete
this room Jenny that's what I'm trying
to do
so we still have everybody in there
like why can't we just
why can't we just delete this
you can only join when you're on the
same server right right so yeah this is
opal eye guys
all right I guess we'll just have to
give it a new name
so I'm gonna back out and we'll try this
tournament without the the overlay and
everything somebody was saying
like what is the X for right there
I'm gonna create another one maybe it'll
automatically delete it
all right so we're gonna call this one
retro rack and tour
two
retroact Couture two that's the one you
want to look for this time
all right so that was pretty cool the
Hightower was pretty fun Let's do let's
do the dragon arena
we're gonna make this one 16 spectating
is allowed
I just hit the X by accident
sorry well we're all learning here on
the Fly
okay we're not gonna ban anything
gonna do that one gonna do 16 allow
spectating as create that's what we need
to do
servers
no
oh wait do you mean just can you in
general
I thought you were saying can I switch
servers I think you I think if you
switch servers you have to make a new
I think you have to make like a second
account
so then reminder guys once you get in
you want to make sure that you're in the
teams and not under viewers so I'm going
to go ahead and join the viewer side
here if we end up being one short I will
hop over and play
but I like being able to move around
freely
I like being able to move around freely
was so worried when you Hermione
obscures me
oh I didn't even pick up on that
or I remember it now that you said it
but I don't think I called it out and
commented on it at the time
new server new character that's what I
was thinking yes yes yes
so wait can North Roger you're on you're
on a North American server but not opal
eye right
because surely you could still see if
you could get in Roger
I wonder if you have to be on opal eye
or if it could be any North American
server to get into the tournament
or are you on opal I Roger
all right so this one is open to more
people guys we're trying to get 16 this
time we got two four six eight nine
right now we got nine people in here so
even if you played in the last one feel
free to hop on in and join this one too
some servers are linked right right
right
you're on the same server okay good
Roger and then Jenny says ridgeback
should be able to connect perfect okay
very nice very nice
all right so witty eggplant got in there
we're gonna be Woody eggplant talking a
big game in the Stream
we might have to to do a little uh sneak
peek of Woody eggplant early here
so summary of that first round Bellatrix
pretty much the
echo of choice right now
which I can't say that I'm too surprised
I love me some Bellatrix man I'm gonna
be getting some tips from you guys too
guy running the locomotor with Bellatrix
something you don't see a lot of
I I typically stay away from them when
I'm running Bellatrix but definitely
giving me something to think about
definitely giving me something to think
about all right we're back up to even
okay so let's see two four six eight ten
oh there's a couple more that just
joined nice nice nice we still have open
spots guys you're looking for retro rack
and two or two and also if you don't
want to play Oh Khaleesi if you're
intending to play you are in the uh
you're in the viewers right now there
you go
yeah guys just uh if you click on this
icon at the bottom right that's just
gonna make sure that you were actually
in the you want to be in the team side
and you do not if you want to play you
don't want to be on the spectator side
but you can also join as a viewer as
well if you want
gonna skip this next I'm gonna be back
on for more after a sounds good sounds
good
wild you're gonna make one make a a
second character just so you can join a
sounds good yeah that's one thing I wish
they would
I mean I understand you have to have
different servers to be able to uh
accommodate players worldwide and keep
lagging everything down but
and like custom games and stuff it'd be
nice if they would let cross server
crossovers join army get two four 6 8 10
. all right we got 12. now let's see if
it would actually let us start it
yeah go ahead and get your deck set guys
and then go ahead and Mark yourself as
ready
because I'm pretty sure engine well
James was doing a Duo tournament and
would not let him start but we are even
okay looks like we still need Twigs to
ready up
I think Twigs is the only one who needs
to ready up
and then I'm gonna try it I'm gonna see
if it'll let us go ahead and start it
send an invite to the club oh man invite
friends
oh dude okay hold on I've played a lot
with you
I've played a lot with you
with you oh Valerie Valerie's in uh
expecto goes community
Ryan are you in here Ryan Ryan get in
here dude
house are you in here get in here
get in here house
why it's not letting me invite house
Social Club oh this is cool this is so
cool oh and it tells me if they're
already in the room like Twigs is
already in the room
discount humor welcome YouTube just now
notified me that you were live what
come on YouTube you gotta get faster on
it hey discount humor if you join our uh
make sure you join up our Discord
and if you're a Twitter person or ex
whatever it's called these days
follow me there I always post it on
Discord and I always post it on Twitter
as well whenever we go live
actually don't even know how YouTube
stream notifications work what does it
normally do email you guys
come on YouTube don't be slacking on us
all right Ryan's in the room let's go
swamp which is in the room
I don't know why it wouldn't let me
invite a house though oh there we go we
invited house
what does it say to you guys on the
other end
all right so we got two four six eight
ten twelve fourteen fifteen we need one
more
there it is
16 let's go oh my goodness it's gonna be
epic all right guys I'll give you one
minute one minute to finish setting your
decks
one minute to set your decks not that I
have power over it because it doesn't
let me start it until everybody's read
it up anyway
actually looks like most people are
readied up already let me double check
Ryan looks like Ryan you're the only one
once Ryan gets uh or Ryan and one other
are not readied up
oh my gosh Roger me too
and I'm not one like
you know people on Twitter are always
freaking out about something I don't I
haven't really paid too much attention
to all the changes and stuff but when
that one happened I was actually kind of
annoyed
I was kind of upset by that one I'm just
I'm like I'm attached all right starting
battle
let's take a look at the match-up list
dirt wizard against giant stranger Draco
against Alice Valerie against sticks
Twigs against Juan Santa against
anecdotal Yoho let's go against Brook
Snape Khaleesi against Ryan De La Cruz
and swamp witch going up against witty
eggplant
oh I already spectated swamp which once
so let's get somebody different this
time let's see here we've already
watched Draco
we've already watched uh giant stranger
let's do something new we'll do uh we'll
get Twigs right here and and Juan
we'll watch them for our first match up
here
muted Discord do I hate me anyways how
hey are we only did one tournament so
far we did an eight eight player solo
tournament and it was it was pretty Epic
it was pretty epic all right let's watch
twigs and one right here
and by the way guys if you are uh
playing the game you can also hop in and
spectate oh it already started what the
heck
what the heck all right so Twigs running
a Bellatrix but one
see what is what is one running
dude why wouldn't it show me this view
before
I have no idea
Juan is running Hermione and also I'm
gonna go ahead and take it to full
screen let's see what you guys think
about this
oh there's the incarceress whizbang no
you guys missed it
no
it's my fault
if you guys don't like it like this
we'll we'll switch it back to the other
view but see like right there you can't
see the player
I mean I guess I could move the webcam
to like the bottom middle
all right twigs
has an uphill climb right here
a pretty significant uphill climb
looks like Juan is running the classic
Hermione deck of
one of the most annoying spells to deal
with right now
you guys already know
all right Twig's getting Ron out
I'm also trying not to commentate too
much on what people have in their hand
because if if the people playing are
also listening to my commentary at the
same time
you only honestly you should probably
mute it guys just for like uh obviously
I can't force people to meet it one with
the victory right there
over Twigs well played one
using uh the whiz-bang incarcerous
to ride to Victory right there GG's
twigs
let's see if we can hop in that one
ended pretty quick let's see if we can
jump into another game before it ends
you got class with a meme deck let's see
oh we still got Valerie and sticks here
let's see if we can catch the the end of
this one
Valerie and sticks maybe maybe is it
loading
might already be done
maybe try Yoho and and Brook Snape over
here all right so dirt wizard moving on
over giant stranger Draco with the win
Khaleesi with the win over Ryan De La
Cruz witty eggplant getting the victory
over swamp witch and then of course Juan
getting the win over twigs and looks
like we're still waiting on these two
right here Valerie and sticks and then
also uh Yoho let's go oh there we go
Brooks Nate moving on and Valerie moving
on
top eight matchups ready to begin
all right I'm gonna watch witty eggplant
I'm gonna watch Khaleesi that's the one
we're gonna watch this time
that is the one we shall spectate
I don't think the spectate it doesn't
pop up right away you have to close out
and then come back in
oh King of the North changed her deck
and you shouldn't have
guy you kept losing to players in the
Korean servers playing locomotor and
Bella started doing it maybe I need to
try it what did you take out when you
put it in
the funny thing is I don't really run a
lot of high cost cards on Bellatrix like
right now I think the highest cost card
I'm running is confringo but
if I had locomotor I might could take
confringo out and put like incendio down
to drop drop the 1mp all right so I want
yeah I like this one where I can see
both cards that's pretty cool
all right so Khaleesi running Hermione
and witty eggplants running Bellatrix
got the monster book doing work early
and now bringing Ron out
Khaleesi can't do anything to combat the
Ron right there just trying to back up a
little bit right now take out the
monster book and now dealing with Ron oh
there comes the stack of Monster books
Woody eggplant's sitting in a stack of
Monster books very very close now to
that first Death Eater
and it has been all witty eggplants so
far the Death Eater kidding Big Time
hits right there
Khaleesi bringing out her mind and out
to try and help out a little bit gets
the thunderstorm going
and Hermione helps out very nicely with
the Death Eater right there while
Khaleesi is still occupied with the
Monster books and you just see all the
damage
the Monster books can do whenever they
have the bombtastic bomb
there's obscurus right there that gets
some good damage in there
and after all that
I mean it felt like Woody eggplant had a
huge advantage
Khaleesi weather the storm nicely and
it's relatively even right now as
Khaleesi deals with uh
Cornish Pixies right now
what do you eggplant running a
similar deck to what I normally like to
run
now we got the bombtastic bomb and the
cats oh those cats are so difficult to
deal with
oh the perfect counter
whenever people run run in that second
slot people have adapted man they have
adapted there's order of water let's see
can she get the Death Eater inside
No No Death Eater inside it's gonna be
very tough for her to come back from
right now and that is gonna do it Woody
eggplant with the victory
moving on right there nicely done
Khaleesi nice job weathering the storm
almost
able to pull the comeback right there
all right let's see if the other matches
are still ongoing or if they have
finished up at this point
giant strangers started to main glacias
to counter locomotor
took it out after you got the Grand
Master
yeah I've been seeing uh quite a bit
more glacias lately
all right so we just got one left looks
like dirt Wizard and Draco still going
man I wish it would let you
it did let us earlier didn't it I guess
that just means that the match is about
oh no wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
we missed it but we hopped in to see
dirt wizard moving on that must have
been an epic fight
that must have been epic if it went down
to the wire
Gigi's dirt wizard dirt wizard moving on
right there so now we are down to our
final four
so I think on the left side we're gonna
have dirt Wizard and Juan moving on and
then on the right we've got anecdotal
versus witty eggplant all right we just
watched witty so this time we'll watch
uh dirt Wizard and one we watched one in
the first game
can't remember who one was playing
though
all right so let's back out and then
open again now it's ready
yeah I I've been experimenting with a
lot of different cards to counter
locomotor you know vintus can work
pretty well confringo can work pretty
well glacias is another one
and sometimes even like acrimential of
venom
watch back to this right here
that way if people are watching the
stream at the same time they both people
have I don't want to give somebody an
advantage by showing things that are on
screen one uh did one switch it up this
time
no Juan running Hermione again okay Juan
on Hermione dirt wizard on Hagrid
dude I feel like that companion right
there those twins I feel like they're
underrated
I don't see people use them a lot but
dude they can be so annoying
there's incarceress but the Wiz Bank
coming a little late
a little late and as a result dirt
wizard not taking the full damage from
it which is very good for dirt wizard
right there
so once you know that that's the kind of
deck people are gonna run once you see
that they're gonna be running
the whiz-bang
it really does change up how you have to
play you just want to basically
overwhelm them as much as you possibly
can forcing them to use their high cost
cards
and not trying to save it up for
whizbang
all right so it's 2214 to 1756 dirt
wizard with an advantage right now and
calling him protego diabolica
not a card you see used a lot
at least not in solos I don't see it a
lot I see it a lot more in Duos I feel
like
Juan right now just content to hide in
the nebulous let the if he build there
it is the incarcerates The Whiz bang
that's gonna hit for the full effect
almost the full effect right there dirt
wizard escaping just a little bit of it
at the tail end now Juan having to
contend with the Opel eye gets the
atmospheric charm
and that is it for the opal eye very
very even match right now
yeah the Tebow's assault with a Hermione
deck not something you see a lot of but
that was a nice move right there
incarceros whiz being again folks I'm
telling you I just made a video about it
just made a video it is so ridiculously
op
P if you can't overwhelm the opponent
it's almost impossible to contend with
so it looks like one is about to pull
this comeback
dirt wizard trying to hold on here oh
unfortunately the atmospheric charm it's
gonna go over to the bomb box though
and that's going to do it right there
the incarcerous pulling them into oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
yeah I was about to say I don't think
dirt wizard has any way to recover any
health
don't think dirt wizard had any way to
recover health so one moving on let's
see if the other game has ended just yet
and that puts Juan moving on to the
finals
GG's well played well played
oh wait oh wait that's already it who
moved on witty eggplant oh dude I'm
actually really really excited for this
matchup
because it's two very different styles
into the game in 11 seconds okay
unless they've changed up their decks
which I I don't think they have I think
are you committed to the deck for the
whole time
um
because it should be two contrasting
Styles here we got one running Hermione
running the whiz-bang also the Tebow's
assault being used with a Hermione deck
in some ways that I haven't seen it
being used before
and then on the other side you've got
woody eggplant running the classic
Bellatrix
with the bomb box with the cats
with the
atmospheric charm the Monster books
here we go guys this is the finals
of the second
try wizard Tuesday tournament right here
I'm gonna switch back to this one
and Woody eggplant getting started right
away with the bombtastic bomb and the
monster book
so there goes Tebow's assault right
there and it's gonna take out the
monster or the uh bomb box
now Juan we saw this earlier having to
deal with the Pixies dude witty eggplant
you and I use almost the exact and
there's the whiz Bang
there's the whiz-bang with the
incarceress
bringing out Ron whereas Juan uses the
atmospheric charm Juan says I got Ron
too
hiding in the nebulous for a little bit
very even fight right now
I I am actually super curious to see how
this ends because I usually play a lot
of Bellatrix and whenever I run into
this people running this Hermione deck
it's really difficult for me to deal
with
there's the Tebow's assault again Juan
using expulso to throw the Death Eater
off but doesn't take it out big damage
for the Death Eater Big Time damage
takes one all the way down to 1587
Health witty still sitting over 2000 HP
right now and now Juan has a whole stack
of Monster books to deal with I mean we
all know witty knows what one is try to
do it there it is
there it is the incarceros whiz Bang
but I don't know that it's gonna be
enough
calling out McGonagall now hits the
inflators in the atmospheric charm I
love it I love it also Tebow's assault
forcing Woody eggplant to move
and look at that one just like that one
turning things around
that's what I love about this game dude
you can turn things around so quick
Woody eggplant calling in the stack of
Monster books there's incarcers and
inflatives no whiz-bang
in coursers inflatus and then the
atmospheric charm here comes the Death
Eater though
one being forced to use whiz-bang to oh
that's gonna do it that's gonna do it
that's gonna do it witty eggplant nicely
done well played and as a Bellatrix
player myself
have to tip my cap dude Woody eggplant
we run like the same deck
we run almost the exact same deck
it's a good deck what can I say is the
game bugged or something aren't we
supposed to be seeing Woody eggplant
right here
I feel like we should be seeing you
that's how you do it folks when you come
in and you talk a big game and you're
able to back it up
what can you say well played tip your
cap to them
well done well done
want someone to play oh my gosh that
that drives me crazy too
all right let's see if we have anybody
drop out if anybody doesn't want to play
anymore feel free to go ahead and leave
the room
so here was our our top two was Woody
eggplant and Juan
dirt Wizard and anecdotal rounding out
the top four well played guys well
played
um let's see where can I see right here
all right so two four six eight oh yeah
so we we went back getting ahead of
myself I'm getting so excited
dude I love tournaments man I love
tournaments
all right if you guys want back in
anybody watching the stream right now
you want to look for the room called
retro rack and tour two
we have Valerian guy is in Lolly is in
Jasmine okay good we're getting a couple
new names in there too Khaleesi Draco
Brooke and guys even if you play it and
the other ones feel free to hop in again
it doesn't look like we're
if we have to start turning some people
away then we'll we'll ask some of the
people who've played a while to maybe
hop out and give the others a chance uh
Ryan just so you know you're in The
Spectator area right now as long as
that's what you intend that is totally
fine
but just so you guys know if you if you
haven't done the duels or the
tournaments in this game before whenever
you hop in so you want to find our room
first so go to Dueling look at the icon
on the top left
I'm pretty sure it's the one at the very
top you click that
and then you want to look for the room
retro rack and tour 2.
you had to close the stream yeah that's
what we were saying it's like if you
don't close the Stream
it would be hard listening to me at the
same time plus I also thought that would
kind of get people Advantage if if
they're seeing the cards that the other
person has
um but yeah well played dude well played
I was saying um
hey if you're gonna talk the talk you
gotta be able to back it up and you
backed it up
you backed it up my friend and I also
said you and I run like the exact same
deck
we we run like the exact same deck
that's my favorite deck that I that I
run as well I feel like we might have
met up in in duels before because I feel
like I remember seeing your name
I'm almost positive we've played let's
see if we have any room left guys retro
record tour two is what you're looking
for two four six eight ten twelve we've
got four spots available right now
four spots available
and if you are in go ahead and ready up
I'm pretty sure it won't let me start it
without 16 but
I am
I'm gonna try try to start it without
laughs
you're new so you'll play the next one a
sounds good Steven all good
feel free to hop in as a as a spectator
right now if you want
but yeah guys if you're if you're
jumping in you have to click this little
icon in the bottom right and then you
have to click teams make sure that you
join the team side if you want to play
you added me a long time ago and never
seen you told me this a few video
oh that that we run the same deck
yeah dude we do we spectated um we
spectated two of your games that time
especially the last one
but yeah I was like wait this is like
the same deck that I run
I mean it's it's a good deck it's a good
deck
so that's where I remember your name we
added each other then all right
all right let's see what we're at now
too I wish there were all right
suggestion to the magic awakened team
there should be something
okay 14 oh wait that's it right there
isn't it 14 and 2. so two are in
spectating
and 14 are readied up two four six eight
ten twelve fourteen yes that's exactly
what it is
all right I'm gonna see if everyone if
virage and one other Ready's up let's
see if it'll let us start it
I feel like it's gonna need the full 16.
Jenny hey come on Jenny you can do it
it's a good way to get better
I mean honestly doing it in a setting
like this might be an even better way to
get to get better because I have balance
mode on so everybody's
um taken down to the same HP which do
you know Draco I know you would know the
answer to this does the does the balance
mode also balance the card levels
surely it does right or is it just
balancing HP
all right we're at 14 and 2 still so we
need
we need two more to uh join in
to join into the tournament and
everybody to ready up and I'll see if I
can start it
if we end up being one short I'll hop in
and uh and play actually know what I
should probably set my deck if I do have
to jump in and play
giving you guys the little yeah I'm
already I'm already good
16 there we go we got 16.
it does level of cards as well oh that's
oh that's that is so awesome dude
I'm gonna be running these all the time
then man
and now I kind of want to hop in here
and play
because I'm hitting the point honestly I
don't mind spending money on this game
I I want to support the developers
because I think it's a really good game
but
I also kind of like playing the role of
trying to see how far I could get as a
free-to-play player
and I made it all the way to Grand
Master but now I feel like I keep
running into people with just way more
HP than me
just much higher spell book levels
so I was kind of thinking about buying
the uh
the battle the magic pass or whatever
it's called
but I love that you can do this without
oh we're ready we're ready let's go
let's go all right so you can check your
matchups now guys we got twin dogs
versus Twigs Brook Snape versus fupa
Lolly versus swamp witch Kayla Renee
versus uh brujo or bruyo
yosvani versus guy Valerie versus
Khaleesi uh Juan versus Stephen Draco
versus Big Jim oh witty you're not gonna
play in this one
come on witty get back in there defend
your title
all right let's watch uh I wanna watch
Brooke Snape
I want to watch Brooke play this one
let's spectate Brooke here
now it's doing the thing where it won't
let me it won't let me spectate the
other person
by the way guys do you have do you have
a preference for
do you like it like this in terms of the
overlay for the screen where my webcam
is here or do you like it where
I have the full screen in the middle and
then like all the little overlays around
it I'll let you guys say what you prefer
I don't understand why the spectators
screen is different
full screen game okay so like this right
here gotcha
yeah I mean I feel like this is probably
the best spot for my webcam
it only hides when they're
when I'm in the uh if they're like in
the top left where Brooke's going right
now actually
all right so we
evos match right now between fupa and
Brook Snape cindio where why is it not
letting me
stranger do you know a witty eggplant do
you know you thought it was great the
other way yeah I kind of prefer the
other one but
why can I not like in that last
tournament I could switch between
both players
I don't know why it's not letting me
this time anyway Brook Snape with a
Death Eater on the field
also with the Malfoy gang on the field
fupa also getting hit by atmospheric
charm right now as Brooke already starts
to build up another Death Eater meter
Here Comes Ron that's probably a good
play
to bring out Ron try to weather this
storm a little bit get the essence of
Disney going get the healing going Brook
hiding out in the nebulous to avoid Ron
a little bit there gets a protego
diabolica
and Ron just not gonna go in there's a
stack of Monster books all right all
right
see I wish I could know what Echo fupa
is running
if you go into your editor for stream
you can resize the oh yeah yeah I know
that
but I mean like still where where would
we put it
it's like in this mode it's going to be
covering up something no matter what
two Death Eaters on the field
and that is gonna do it for fupa two
Death Eaters plus Ron Brook Snape moving
on ggs
well played well played
internet down for maintenance Roger no
all right see if we can hop in and catch
another end of the end of another game
so far we haven't been able to to catch
two open to spectators
Valerie and Khaleesi let's go
come on
come on take me in there
oh oh oh we might we might see the end
come on game load
oh
darn it we missed the end
oh no
oh no I might be stuck here
no
I shouldn't have done it
I shouldn't have done it we're stuck
oh great
I'm gonna have to completely quit out of
the game I think
hopefully it doesn't shut down the room
I don't think it does though I think the
room just keeps on going
all right
that's happened to you before
yikes I shouldn't have tried
okay good yeah it keeps it going nice
we should be able to catch most of the
next game as long as it lets us in
pretty quick here
put yourself on the dragon resize it not
to be on the field
oh like in the in the middle yeah we
could try that or it's like right in the
middle of the screen I still can't
figure out why the overlays were
different because
the one time when I was watching you
play witty that whole tournament I could
switch between
either player
but then this tournament for some reason
it's not letting me switch back and
forth
all right oh it brought me right back in
oh dude this is perfect they haven't
started yet
perfect perfect perfect
round two open inspectors all right
twigs and Brooke Lolly and brujo
Juan uh yosvani and Valerie let's watch
them
Valerie and I played a bunch of Duos
a couple weeks back
and got Valerie to I think I think we
got Valerie to Grand Master
always somebody else to host now first
person spectating wait this is what I
want
yes because then I can see both of them
see that's like I feel like that's too
small oh wait this
uh I don't know if I like that better I
feel like that's covering
I feel like I'm too I don't I don't like
being that close to the middle
I will make it a little bit smaller
though kind of tuck it away here monster
the top left corner and you can see a
little bit more of the of the field
all right so yeah see this is the
perfect view right here
we've got a newt and
why will it not let me see
okay Newt versus Haggard oh my gosh
the spam decks
oh it didn't totally boot me perfect
all right so yosvani and Valerie here
running two Decks that we haven't seen a
lot of tonight
we've got Newt on yosvani side here
using Ventus to just perfection right
there
keeping the Malfoy gang at Bay
and getting the easy KO of them right
there Valerie gonna send out the monster
book
let's see what is Valerie running it's
kind of the big card over there for
Hagrid
oh I see it I see it it might be coming
up there it is
antipody and opalai is out on the field
trying to take out Hermione but now it's
got some locomotors to deal with too
he rumpets with a nice hit right there
also gets Valerie gets the swelling
solution going
Debo's assault and now calls out Ron as
well oh that was a great play
that even things up right there
but now Valerie has to let the MP build
back up
also with the Whomping Willow right in
the middle of the field here comes
another opal eye
dude the whopping Willow coming in
clutch right there
one of carusio's best uses in duels
right there for taking out the the big
boys like the opal eye
Tebow's assault coming in Valerie moves
away just in time now Valerie's sending
a Tebow
there it is big hit and Valerie has
completely turned this fight around
the Whomping Willow right now proving a
great little buffer
to provide just enough defense
from the locomotors
now Valerie's MP running low though the
locomotors right up right up in her face
just though just in time though she gets
the opal eye out
has two more locomotors come onto the
field yosvani trying to bring this fight
back yosvani also with McGonagall on the
field now as well
McGonagall working on the Opel eye right
there doing a pretty decent job of
keeping it busy
opal I just with a tiny tiny bit of
Health left and you can see the
thunderstorm takes it out there essence
of Disney going as well there comes
another opal eye
and now yosvani has taken the lead here
spelling solution we are officially past
three minutes so they are now taking
damage just as the time ticks as well
Valerie healing Here Comes Tebow's
assault and she can't block it even the
erupted will not block it she's down to
34 HP and the time is going to tick off
boy was that a tight very very close
match right there that was just tight
the whole way back and forth
yosvani had the early Advantage then
Valerie took the advantage looked like
Valerie was going to have the victory
then yosvani bringing it back in the end
well played
dude these matches have been crazy good
I love it
all right I'm not going to try to jump
into any more games guys sorry even if
we see oh we're at the finals final four
rather sorry not the finals yosvani
versus Draco and Lolly versus Twiggs
still moving on let's go twigs
all right I think we're gonna spectate
uh have I spectated Twigs yet I think I
spectated Twigs once already and we
spectated Draco too so
let's do we just watched you usvani so
let's hop over here we'll watch twigs
and Lolly this time
hahaha
so it's I need to get in what they call
first person spectator
do you know Jenny like what I don't know
what why it would have changed like why
sometimes it's not yeah so here we go
first person spectating I click on twigs
and there we go perfect
just another example all right so we got
Bellatrix versus Bellatrix here
thunderstorm versus thunderstorm
Hermione versus Hermione
I feel like we're seeing some mirror
images of each other right now
of course Draco already has the obscurus
card or no that was wait we're not
watching Draco that was Lolly with the
obscurus card
Twigs using spiders
another one I don't see a lot with the
Bellatrix deck
Death Eater on the field for Lolly Twigs
getting very close to a Death Eater as
well
oh dude this atmospheric charm is
melting right now I don't know if Twigs
realizes
all the way down to 1637 and now the
Death Eater staring him right down
Death Eater taken out atmospheric charm
now Twigs getting the Death Eater out
but right after Lolly cast thunderstorm
if the Death Eater even makes it it's
gonna be so weak by the time it does
gets in just a little bit of damage
but that was some unfortunate timing for
Twigs right there
great play by Ron right there Lolly just
played Ron as well
gonna take out the baby manticores
atmospheric charm now from Lolly to try
and take out Ron Lolly with a pretty
sizable Advantage here and also getting
very close to bringing two Death Eaters
out on the field Twiggs trying to use
the fire crab but man you see the power
of the new card right there
you see the power of obscurus
baby manticores on the field
Lolly also getting very close to another
Death Eater probably gonna get it right
there
with the atmospheric charm so we got
atmospheric charm we got Death Eaters
we got the bomb box this might be it for
Twigs right here I don't know if Twigs
has enough to weather this storm
gets an incendio off oh wait wait wait
wait
Death Eaters on the field Malfoy gang on
the field
fire crab on the field
look at that though
Hagrid dude Haggard just running over
the dead theaters before they can do
anything
oh the Ventus came out a little bit too
late for the monster book and that's
gonna do it
great match Lolly
very very well played right there by
Lolly
again two Bellatrix decks going at it
something we have seen a lot of tonight
and then on the other side we had let's
see if we have a winner yet
let's see if we have a winner going into
the grand finals
yosvani and Draco oh I bet that's a good
one I bet that's a good game going I
don't want to hop in though because I'm
afraid it will it will crash on us again
um
so somebody tell me I need to read up on
this obscurus card I need to read
exactly what it does
because doesn't it like open you up to
more damage for a bit
because just from the visuals of it it
almost looks like a combination of like
incendio and
oh what's the other one uh the howler
looks like a combination of both of
those cards
oh it's like broomstick
wait really is it a movement
have I have I completely missed the
movement wait let's see who moved on
yosvani getting the victory over Draco
end of the game in three seconds all
right folks this is the finals yosvani
taking on Lolly right here
oh you actually turn into it so so were
you that little ring over there I'm
gonna have to watch more carefully
ah
we'll see if Lolly I'll pay attention
when Lolly uses it here
all right so we got Newt against
Bellatrix
Lolly against yosvani for the grand
finals here yosvani bringing out the
locomotors and the bomb box early
plays Hermione and thunderstorm
yosvani gonna go ahead and take that
opportunity to bring out Ron let's see
if Lolly has anything to try and deal
with Ron
throws the baby manticores to move
around a little bit
right now yosvani definitely playing
more on offense
whereas Lolly I mean you see this almost
any game where locomotives are used oh
and Ron gets the chess piece as well
just about any game where somebody is
running the locomotors
the question becomes how are they going
to deal with them
despite all of this lolli's HP not
looking too bad Wally been doing pretty
solid on defense
and getting very close to the first
Death Eater
but yosvani is a new player
kind of starting to reach that point
where there are so many things on the
field that it becomes overwhelming
let's see if lolly can turn this around
gets the Death Eater to take
unfortunately just just bad timing with
when that Death Eater came out because
Vani using crucio
and then there's Hermione with
thunderstorm
oh no I don't think Lolly has any way to
avoid it
no nebulous
Wally's gonna take the full
I think Lolly played Baby manticores to
try and spread out the thunderstorm
damage just a little bit
but it may be too late yosvani with a
sizable Advantage right here we've yet
to see the obscurus card being played
yosvani just building up that Army back
there as newt
the Thunderbird going giving Shield to
the locomotors
Hagrid though
coming in clutch right there helping to
take out the locomotors but she's got to
get away from it
Haggard with just a little bit of Health
left
all right Lolly letting the MP build up
for something there come the Death
Eaters
baby manticors the Death Eaters are
gonna take care of the locomotors and
the rumpent
but there comes McGonagall the companion
play from yosvani okay there's obscurus
right there
oh yeah I see so you kind of do like a
little teleport
so you teleport over there for a little
bit and then
um
stranger doesn't it also make you or guy
whoever was saying that
doesn't it also make you take more
damage for like the next five seconds or
something
I think I read that
yosvani's Health still very strong and
now we are officially over three minutes
it's gonna be very hard for Lolly to
bring this back to have any hope of it
gonna need the Death Eaters to do some
big time work right here and they are
just absolutely zapping
the locomotors
locomotives are gone locomotors are off
the field
one Death Eater still remaining is Vince
is going to be able to finish off I
think it should
yes Death Eater is gone
Lolly with only 244 but look at that
look how fast
oh my goodness is Lolly gonna bring it
back Yo's body down to 35 and the
comeback is complete
dude I looked away from their HP for two
seconds
oh my goodness the the triple Death
Eaters
I thought the Death Eaters were were
destroying the locomotives but was one
of the Death Eaters actually damaging
the other player
oh my goodness Lolly what a match
yosvani GG's well played that was so
incredibly close man
I'm watching it back on stream right now
for some reason my stream
oh wait is this this isn't live right
I was like this is way delayed I don't
know how it got so far delayed
wow gee geez what a match when it ends
you take 40 more damage for a few
seconds gotcha that's what I was
thinking Mia so if you can yeah so if
they use that you want to really try and
be ready to do damage quick
all right so here are results for that
one lolly and yosvani gee geez that
match that was that was probably the
closest match we've seen so far
I I did not see Lolly turning that
around
two eggs and then Draco rounding out the
top four we will play another one guys
we will play another one Ryan De La Cruz
and Lolly just just a heads up you guys
are in the viewer category now
people if you're watching the stream
let's see how many we have 11 guys so we
have room for five more to join this is
a room for up to 16 players we have
balance mode on right now we are not
Banning any cards we are not Banning any
Echoes the room you want to look for is
retro rack and tour two
you can join up we are in the Opel eye
server I believe if you're on any North
American server you will be able to join
and play
oh no we're dropping down no don't leave
the room
don't leave let's do more attorneys
back up to nine now okay
you only take 40 more damage at the end
of obseries if there isn't an enemy hit
by the final hit
okay wait if there isn't an enemy hit so
if you hit an enemy
with the final hit then you don't take
40 more damage oh wow that's an
interesting little
wait a minute I can pull up the card
right here can I
even though I don't have it I just have
to click that little button
it only costs five doesn't it
okay here we go oh my goodness it's Max
damage transforms you into an invisible
obscurus launching six rapid basic
attacks on random enemy units in the
Target area while briefly slowing them
wow well briefly selling them okay wait
Draco
talk to me
Snape Echo
does it do
septum sempra attacks
because
that would kind of be the go-to card for
Snape if so
after the attacks the target Zone
explodes dealing massive damage to All
Enemies inside and erasing the obscura
status you then return to your starting
point if there are no opponent units in
the Target area
the area will be detonated and the
attack will end
when the obscurus effect wears off you
are weakened and take 40 more damage for
five seconds
oh so that's
that's only if this is true interesting
okay
I did not pick up on that at first
it's so this this second bullet point
here apparently is only true if this
happens
never tried Snape people seem to think
that will work oh my gosh
whoo
that would be pretty crazy
that would be pretty crazy you hopped in
Jenny all right oh we're at 15.
oh
all right I'll give it like one minute
if nobody joins I'll hop in and join
glimmer gold glimmer if you uh are
intending to be a participant you need
to click on this little icon over here
in the bottom right and then you want to
click on teams and then click join or if
you want to hang out in The Spectator
room that's fine too
oh there we go we got it we got 16.
we got 16. all right I'm gonna remind
everyone to get ready we are ready for
another tournament man I should have
been keeping track of all the winners
here
guys if you're new here thank you so
much for stopping by and hanging out out
I've been having an absolute blast with
Harry Potter magic awakened we post
videos here every week on YouTube we
posted a lot of Hogwarts Legacy content
and we'll post a lot more Hogwarts Lexi
content leading up to
I hope when they put it put out a DLC I
hope when they put out a sequel
and lately we've been covering Harry
Potter magic awaken and occasionally
cover some other uh gaming content as
well
so thank you all for being here
if you're interested in supporting the
stream make sure you subscribe to the
channel here on YouTube it is totally
free to subscribe if you wish to support
the channel uh becoming a channel member
you can do that as well
and that would really go a long way to
help me also unlock some emotes
and we are ready to start the new battle
but yeah if you if you become a member
we call it housewrecking tour you also
get a special role in our Discord
anytime we do game nights you get
priorities so special little perks like
that but mostly it's just a a nice way
for people to support the stream if they
want let's check the match up list we
got pink versus Juan we got Lolly versus
Khaleesi Valerie swamp which Damia
versus Nikki hey we got Dylan in the
house Dylan what's up Dylan going
against Twigs Kayla against Draco Brooke
against guy and zanatsu against Stephen
dude I gotta watch my boy Dylan
I gotta watch my boy Dylan here in the
first game
Dylan versus twigs
okay see now it's not first person
what the heck why did that happen you
guys I do not understand the spectating
why it switches up like that
don't understand it
it's all good we already know what
people are running we got Dylan running
uh Bella and also Twigs running Bella so
we got two Bellas
against each other yet again
Hermione the first companion for Twigs
Dylan bringing out Ron
wait is Dylan
is Dylan AFK does Dylan know the MP is
full there we go
it's like wait a second
Dylan's just just setting up the timing
on everything
setting up the timing
so wow Ron that actually did not take
out Hermione's still up Dylan get the
bombtastic bomb going while the
cats are over there doing work also the
Monster books oh dude
that Death Eater did some damage right
there
but now Dylan gets a Death Eater out
so Twigs just right now trying to
survive the onslaught of Monster books
dealing with all the Monster books here
early
all right there's Ron and here comes Ivy
Dylan ready for it
Dylan's been watching my videos Dylan
knows what's up Dylan was ready for that
one
I think it's so funny to see how people
have like changed up where they use Ron
when that card first dropped everybody
had run in the first slot
then people started running Ivy now
people put Ron in the second slot now
people are running ivy in the second
slot
this is so funny Hey Jake what's up
welcome in
dude don't be talking about Chick-fil-A
gonna make me hungry
oh that atmospheric charm completely
neutralizing one of Dylan's Death Eaters
the fire crab over there the confringo
takes care of the fire crab dealing with
a nice Advantage right here
Twigs very close to a Death Eater that's
probably going to be twigs's only chance
to bring this one back to based on a
thunderstorm but the atmospheric charm
by Dylan right there well played well
timed nicely done Dylan moving on ggs to
both competitors there
dude that was nice Dylan tweaks made it
pretty far in the in the in the last
tournament
very very impressive win right there
from Dylan
let's hop on over to The Spectator so
Lolly defeated Khaleesi Nikki defeated
Damia we got Stephen over zanato Brooke
and guy still uh the last the last one
over here Draco defeated Kayla and then
of course Dill in the match we spectated
taking out Twigs right there ggs
everybody ggs let's see we still got two
going oh wait Valerian swamp which too
they're still over here
what's my dude like everything right
like it pretty much everything
no I I like the chicken sandwich a lot
and then the chicken strips you can't go
wrong with either of those
all right round one ends in 10 seconds
oh wait it hit the wrong thing
so guy defeated Brook and swamp which
defeated uh Valerie so there we go
that takes us to the top eight
the top eight of the next round
oh wait I hate that you also have to
back out and then go back in to spectate
ah
dude some of these matches have been so
good
so good
oh man Draco and Dylan would be a good
one
let's watch guy and Steven
guy and Steven
said he was new let's see if see if
Stephen was lying to us or not
we should be able to tell pretty quick
because guy is a really good player I
think guy won the the first tourney
tonight
oh Twigs that's you
I kept asking what was your name King of
the North
all right so we got Bellatrix guy
switching it up this time guy not
running Bellatrix
oh wait we actually can do the first
person spectator this time guy running
Dobby oh my goodness guy trying to run
the Avada deck
the Avada deck is tough to pull off
let's see
all right there's there's one no no wait
did that take out Hermione I think it
did
I think it did oh yeah that I think
that's what the little green indicator
means
but Steven with a huge Advantage I don't
think guy's done any damage whatsoever
yet on Steven wait what Steven's running
Avada too
we got double avadas in here are you
kidding me
Steven running Avada on a Bellatrix deck
which is not something that I've seen
too often
all right guy getting the bludgeer going
now
Steven's gonna have two Death Eaters
this time
and barely any health taken away
dude if guy pulls this back
if guy somehow wins this then we should
just like
best player in the game
I don't know if you're muting the stream
while you're playing but guy if you
somehow pull this back
okay wait yep yep yep that's two of us
that's two of honest oh my gosh imagine
if he gets in a bottle to win this
I will lose my mind
that that might be what guy guys guys
won for the dramatic
oh wait wait wait oh
I thought he got the third
I don't think he's gonna be able to
weather the storm long enough though
Steven's just keeping the pressure on
oh there's
he needs one more
Steven's got to overwhelm him Steven's
gotta go throw everything he has
thunderstorm Stephen you gotta get him
out of them there you go there you go
there you go
okay well let's see let's see
guylet
oh my gosh he needs he needs one more AK
he's down to 379 health
Steven trying to keep
oh okay that's four that's four that's
four
that's four he's got it
oh 107 107 64. no
oh my gosh dude if you pull that off I
would have lost my mind
oh Steven well played you just beat a
really good player trying to run the
Avada deck
oh my goodness dude
I would have lost my mind if he pulled
that off
oh wow and round two ends right there
would you look at that we got pink and
Nikki Dylan versus Stephen for the final
two
to go to the finals
oh man I'm gonna spectate pink and Nikki
we haven't watched uh
watched either of them
oh you're new Street Stephen I thought
she meant you were new to the game I was
like oh
I feel kind of bad if you get matched up
against somebody that's really good
and then I'm like wait is that guy
you're you're not new to the game trying
to practice that deck
it's tough to do man especially against
the player that like knows what they're
doing
I love it when you have somebody who's
clearly running that deck though and and
you're just if you're running like
Hermione deck or something and you I'm
just like casting spells there's nothing
they can do
then they just start casting Avada on me
oh two Snips oh dude I'm actually really
pumped to see this
we haven't seen any Snips tonight this
is the first snapes that we've spectated
this I haven't gotten a good Snape Echo
yet
I mean you pretty much need to get Time
Turner on the Snape Echo I feel like to
make it worthwhile because that card is
just a must
for Snape
but I think this car would be or this
Echo would be so fun to learn
all right so both of them running even
though they're both running Snape you
can see down there at the bottom we've
got
three different cards
obviously both gonna have time Turner
and right now Manticore moves going for
Pink as well as bludger
which
I feel like was underrated for a while
but now people people understand how
good it can be
and it can be so annoying to deal with
so very annoying to deal with
also bringing out Ron right there at the
same time
that's a big push from Pink right there
Big Time push
really really good damage a 1 000 HP
Advantage right there
now let's see what Nikki can do if Nikki
can do anything to bring this back
somehow pink actually ahead and
MP right now as well
Akio another staple of a lot of Snape
users they want to get you in close
Nikki playing
locomotives to try and just backpink up
a little bit oh look wait locomotors on
Snape and swelling Solution on Snape
one of the locomotors already down let's
see if this one can do a little bit of
damage
did indeed get a little bit of damage
for Nikki but I don't think it's going
to be enough
unless I mean maybe we see another
insane comeback there's obscurus right
there
accio whoa
dude the accio right after the obscurus
because it was doing extra damage
my gosh pink well played that extra
damage
can't play as much as I would like
between working four kids
yeah yeah you got a lot going on for
sure
Lauren welcome in good to see you Lauren
all right let's see if the other side
has been decided yet
and we can get ready for this finals
this is uh this will be the last match
right here
Jake dude our boy Dylan let's go
Dylan moving on to the final round I
know Dylan's been putting a lot of time
in dueling in this game
you love to see it
Dylan against pink and we're gonna get
to see two different styles right here
you got pink running the Snape Echo you
got Dylan running the Bellatrix Echo
and clearly we have seen we've actually
been able to spectate both of them in
the lead up to this
and we know that they are both very
talented players so I'm anxious to watch
this
hopefully it gives me the correct view
here
by the way if anybody uh watching this
later in the replay Squad if you guys
know
how to get the correct spectator mode
I'm just not sure what I'm doing
different I feel like I'm doing the same
thing every time yeah this this is the
one I want right here so we can see both
of their cards
here it goes
all right Dylan getting the cats out
early and the Monster books you can see
Dylan didn't have the bomb box early
which whenever I'm playing Bellatrix and
I don't get a bomb box early it always
annoys me nice confringo right there
almost taking it and yeah Kevin's gonna
be gone now
got a few baby Manta cores to deal with
Dylan's gonna go ahead and call out Ron
to take care of those manticores pink
using nebulous dude why is I feel like
nebulous is so inconsistent I really do
because it's still hit right there
for some reason
then Dylan following up on it with the
stack of Monster books Pink's got the
Clone
doing some work right now Dylan getting
very close to a Death Eater though and a
pretty good Advantage right now
but the bludger is out
the bludger is out which forces a lot of
movement from the other player almost by
necessity
there's the bludger aiming right at the
Death Eater and completely neutralizing
the Death Eater
as we move into the second phase of the
fight Dylan's sending in the monster
book he knows it's going to go through
that nebulous like no problem
also have the cats in there too getting
the bomb box going
this fight so far Dylan has been totally
on the offensive
all right now pink has two time Turners
going plus Ron
oh no Dylan's Ivy missed Ivy missed
will that be the turning point in the
fight Dylan was going to take out Ron
with Ivy but instead Ivy locked on to
one of Pink's clones and now you can see
Ron still here remaining on the field
doing damage over time to Dylan that has
completely turned this fight
oh there's two time three time Turners
now
can the Death Eaters help Dylan turn
this fight there's two Death Eaters on
the field Dylan throwing out an incendio
there's some nice damage right there
and here comes the bludger again dude
look at look at all of them they're
still over there
perfectly played confringo right there
if ever Dylan needed a card that was the
one he needed right there but there's
Akio
accio with another time Turner
Dylan gets out the Malfoy gang just to
try and help him have a little bit of
breathing room and there's the stack
stack of Monster books go rushing in
just when McGonagall is played
Dylan getting the incendio in there
oh this is gonna be close you guys this
is going to be close three Death Eaters
about to come onto the field right now
you're not gonna be able to take out all
of them with a bludger that's for sure
Pink's still with an HP Advantage but
pink has to oh dude look at this they're
lining up perfectly for the bludger are
you serious
oh my goodness the bludger again
accio oh my goodness no Dylan caught in
between oh there's the stack of Monster
books and he's got the ball box out
unfortunately it is now over three
minutes so Dylan also has to be
concerned about that too he's got the
bomb box he's got the cats he's got the
Monster books doing everything he can I
don't think he's gonna have enough time
to wait for More Death Eaters
atmosphere charm is a great play right
there but there's the accio
win
pink with the victory
just barely just barely
Dylan made a valiant Valiant attempt
right there but guys I'm telling you the
turning point of the fight
was the ivy Miss
sometimes it just it just happens you
know
Ivy's a little bit you have to you have
to get the aim just right and if you
bump something or if there's if there's
another enemy or something that comes
onto the field in your view
sometimes it can be a little tricky
I feel like that was the turning point
in the fight Dylan had the advantage
early
pink wedded the storm though and right
there folks if you haven't seen the
power of the Snape Echo
I think that right there had it on full
display that moment when pink had I
think it was three clones out at the
same time all
all doing the sectum simbra
unbelievable all right let's take a look
at our results Here Pink coming out on
top of the victory well played well
played Dylan at number two Nikki and
Steven rounding out the top four and
guys look at this man if you're here
watching the stream we've got a lot of
spaces open
we will run this back again
we have plenty of spaces open we are at
six right now we can fit 16 here in the
room
so if you guys are hanging out watching
want to play I know Jenny mentioned
possibly doing a Duo tournament Jenny
said so if you have a chance at at
winning
oh yeah it's all good Jake I think uh
Robo Panda hasn't been able to play as
much so
I think Dylan was uh trying to switch
out roommates
you can kind of control deployment of
Death Eaters yeah there's a couple ways
you can control deployment like
like if you have something like a
broomstick or
just wear your positioned
generally
we'll see if we can get if we can get
I'm gonna try to get one more full 16
player solo
and then if we do that I think we can we
can hop out and maybe do some Duos
um all right so we got eight people in
right now we need to get uh we need to
double that we need to get up to 16
we've got three people spectating guys
if it's your first time dueling make
sure you look over here on the right
need to click this little icon right
here
and you want to make sure that you shift
over from viewer to teams I mean you can
also view guys if you're if you want to
just hop in and spectate you can do that
as well but like Dylan right now Dylan I
don't know if you're intending to be in
the viewers but you are currently in the
viewers you need to click on teams and
join up over there so right now we got
Brooke Khaleesi Twigs Aaron Draco swamp
which JW
that's her boy Jake Tony uh Riku Kayla
and then we got Damien just joining in
there as well so still five spots
available guys five spots still open
and baby girl I love it
I love it eggplant
kind of want to hop in and play this
last one man
I kind of want to hop and play
we'll see though we'll see we'll see
that I can't just bounce around and
spectate though
unless I lose which which very well
could happen and happen quickly yeah you
were in there Jake all right we got 11.
we got five spots open
oh wow why it's not win
I thought you meant like I was so pumped
for your tournament win that you had to
go for pizza I was like dang he's really
into this he's really into this game
going to celebrate with pizza
she is your window oh yes
good thing to say good thing to say
battery's so low oh you can't play till
it charges a bit gotcha we're only at 11
guys we got five spots open
I'm gonna go ahead and remind everyone
to get ready
maybe it'll let us start if we have an
even number of players
all right that's it I'm joining
I'm doing it I'm playing in this one I'm
in
I'm in guys let me make sure my I don't
want to show you guys my deck again I'm
not going to show it again
you guys already know what I run anyway
because I I literally post videos about
it on YouTube
yeah we should just invite me sometime
witty eggplant I'm on almost all the
time
I'd love to do some uh matches with you
I could probably learn a lot from you
from your uh your Bellatrix
you know what I need to do woody
eggplant
I need to figure out
a good a good alternative
a good second play because you know once
you hit Grand Master
if you guys haven't made Grand Master
yet once you hit Grand Master and then
get past 8 100.
it switches up a little bit oh we got it
we got it we got it we got 16. we're
there
it switches up a little bit
um
you you pick three decks and then before
the match you can ban
one of the other person's decks so
almost always oh we just dropped down to
15. we need one more guys we need one
more
all right remind to get ready twigs and
one other are not ready and then we
still need one other person to join guys
if you're watching the stream no
pressure
just hop on in
the water's fine it's nice and warm
you'll get some good practice we are
running balance mode so you don't have
to worry about anybody having much
higher level cards it's all good
bet Delia at 12 A.M
I have no idea what that means
bet Delia at 12 A.M don't be driving and
texting
my plant trying to comment
look at Discord Community chat I'll
check it out I'll check after stream
Jake
dual not deal
bet Julia at 12 A.M
oh duel me at 12 like at tonight at 12
a.m okay we're back up to 16. there we
go there we go
all right rxbb and one other are not
ready
Gigi what's up welcome in
and guys if you're one of these four in
the spectators stick around we're going
to be playing uh
we're gonna switch over to
Duos after this oh geez it's already
almost 10 o'clock oh we might have to
push duel this might have to be next
stream guys
do those night Duos might have to switch
over to next weekend
oh we just a spot just opened there's
six people spectating okay somebody just
sniped it rxbb Tony and two others are
not ready
you gotta ready up guys before it'll let
us uh start what's the plant in the room
oh Jake so you have to go to
there's like this little plant that our
dorm room we need to like water it and
stuff
and they're these little things you have
to collect the way that you get to it is
you click on the season tasks
rxbb Tony two others not ready match
cannot begin
all right let's see
I'll do we got a lot of people like
spectating now okay so let's see who all
needs to ready up
wait do I need to ready up hold on
how do I ready up
I can't ready up
rxbb
oh wait I can switch people to spectate
oh that's cool all right rxbb I'm gonna
give you one minute if rxbb is not
readied up
because it looks like rxbb is the only
one
yeah
just rxbb
you just hit start okay good that's what
I was thinking
it doesn't show up though until when
you're the host it doesn't show up until
everybody else is ready all I can do is
remind people to get ready
so those Spectators stand by we might
have a spot opening up
all right RX 10 9 8.
7 oh wait there you go RX got it
let's do it
all right match up oh my goodness I have
to go against Brooke no way Brookstone
Brook's the one who wanted me to join so
bad all right so we got JW Khaleesi Tony
guide Brooke against me swamp witch
Nikki Kayla Aaron Twigs Draco aegon Riku
rxbb Damia
wait how do I okay I was like what how
do I play
I've been spectating all night
took me longer than you care to admit
figure
hey all good Caitlyn
it is a little bit confusing at first
all right guys I'm shifting out of of uh
commentary mode
to play mode
all right I gotta Focus up here
okay we got Bellatrix
probably running two very similar decks
here
would be my guess
Oh I thought she was gonna go with the
thunderstorm
Hermione Candace Mighty couldn't decide
what she wanted to do
come on Cassandra get her get her
Cornish Pixies
see like watch this oh I'm not even
gonna use it but like sometimes nebulous
oh dude she's pretty close to her Death
Eater
there we go nice
I'm gonna wait
[Music]
get him Ron
no get out of that
all right the Death Eater took out Ron
right there
oh that was a bad bad nebulous right
there
and my Death Eaters really haven't been
doing much at all though this match
oh here comes Ron
dang it I mistimed it
get out of here Ron
thank you
suggest
all right go Pixies go
come on out of there
oh both getting very close to Death
Eaters again
there we go
Gigi's Brook ggs
I can't believe I got we got matched up
against you oh man
after Brook was the one who said like
come on retro hop in and play
that's too funny
[Music]
oh no is it already starting oh 15
seconds okay
eat out Luna
all right who are we up against now
good game Brooke don't be bad at me
don't be mad still all love from Brook
there all right Nikki oh dude Nikki made
it pretty far in the last one I think
Nikki's another
well Nikki might have changed but I
think Nikki was Snape player before
blow your mind how amazing this deck is
if you can't play Bella
right
okay what do we have this time
today
all right start start building up that
meter
okay I'm worried like why is she not
casting anything
I don't like it
could be a Hermione
I gotta be watching out for that whiz
Bang
so far she's just been oh there it was
dude I freaking called it
oh my gosh
I called it man
sheesha
oh I don't think I was even getting hit
by that actually
[Music]
dude whenever people are waiting around
like that it's one of two things it's
either Avada
or it's whiz-bang
it's one of the two
every single time
okay see that's what you want to do
like that's the only way you stand a
chance man you have to like you have to
overwhelm them
you just have to completely overwhelm
them with with attacks
because otherwise they can just sit back
they can let the MP build
like see this better protect me from Ron
okay good it actually worked for once
get out of here Ron
here he comes I'm gonna get hit
dude I can I can predict it man I can
freaking predict it
all right I gotta be careful man
I gotta be careful
you guys if you guys have seen my Clips
you know no spell will let you come back
faster than freaking whiz-bang
come on come on come on move move move
move move move move see I told you dude
it's not over
It's Not Over
come on get over there Death Eater
what are you doing
if I get this it's over atmospheric
charm is over
there we go
GJ's Nikki though ggs
all right top four
whew man I I it's whenever people are
just like waiting not casting anything
you know they're they're saving up for
something big what is it what is it
GG it is so fun it is so fun
all right who am I against now Khaleesi
Phillips this time
Khaleesi and me and then Draco and I
think RX on the other side
let's go
let's go let's go
I played with Khaleesi a lot in Duos I
don't think we've ever matched up with
1v1 though
JP thanks appreciate the support JP
all right so Khaleesi not on Bella
all right running the orb of water
though so that probably means Hermione
which also probably means that I need to
stay away
from Cassandra here
yeah see like sometimes nebulous works
perfectly just like that and other times
it doesn't
oh the fire crab
gonna send it to my side
it'll expose so send it back over there
oh and I did just use the exploso
get away Death Eater
oh yes go for her go for her yes
go for her yes
don't worry about that thing here Death
Eater let me help you
don't worry about that
oh my gosh Death Eater yes
that was huge from the Death Eater right
there still not over
but big plays and see we're already
almost to another Death Eater also
all right where's it gonna end up okay
that's we can work with that
no don't spawn right there Death Eaters
no oh no
oh good the other one
the other one's spawned in a good spot
oh that was my that was my fault I
shouldn't went so close with the Death
Eater about to come out
good plays Khaleesi I love man that that
little play with the crabs is such an
interesting one
like sending it on their side of the
field
especially in Duos man it can really
like wreak some Havoc
oh my goodness we got Jenny we got JP we
got Joe
all the Jays
let's go Draco and RX still battling it
out here
let's see who's gonna move on
good game Khaleesi good game
I got scared for a second when I got
stuck in the uh when you when you had
the orb of water and then had me in the
fire crab
whew that was that was a little uh
nerve-wracking there
see I I could try to spectate but I
don't want it to freeze up again
3 30 though this seems like a lot of
time
surely it's not going to take that long
for them to finish
if you guys are just tuning in and you
uh
or if you're watching later on the
replay Squad make sure you check out
these matches because it has been
some epic epic matches tonight let me
tell you
your real life name has JJ no way yeah
my name is Jonathan
as well
so that's another J
oh here we go all right who made it
Draco let's go
oh my gosh
Draco
an experience a very very experienced
player here I believe this is draco's
first finals of the night
draco's had some close ones though I get
some tough players
all right guys game face on
dude I love the little countdown isn't
that awesome
sounds like you're in this Arena three
two one
all right what's Draco gonna be running
what is Draco gonna be running
um see if draco's running Bella I'm
trying to remember what Draco was
running earlier
no not Bella okay
there we go all right we saved Cassandra
that's good that's good
come on Cassandra get rid of Ron Perfect
all right
dang it Draco moved kind of a wasted
confringo right there
fantastic bomb
oh no don't start that
not that
I don't know what Echo Drake I was
running right now
a very methodical style here
from Draco
are about to get the Death Eater out
right there
foreign
that's bad
this is bad I can't move
come on Death Eaters
Death Eaters gotta do some work right
here man
and they did not I don't think we're
gonna be able to bring this back
see now the time's ticking
and we're taking damage
oh ggs Draco what Echo were you running
Newt I think it was Newt right
I don't think I've ever seen that style
be played at all
I was not ready for that well played
oh my gosh why is it not going ahead
that was crazy dude
let's see what was Hagrid
Hagrid and Oso way Opel eye
oh wow
that that was like the least aggressive
Hagrid I've ever seen
and clearly it worked normally haggards
are just like
it's like they're just trying to plow
through everything man
that was just like that was so well
paced Draco ggs good games good games
oh man I think we should do a doubles
tournament I think I love the idea of a
doubles tournament but I think it'll
have to be the another stream
The Keeper of the keys I like it
I like it Keeper of the key no that's a
like all the matches I played I don't
think I've ever seen that particular
style I don't think I've seen it
so Props to you for uh not only playing
it well but just like
all night I haven't seen a style like
that
all right let me switch y'all let me
switch views here
let me switch views here guys oh wait
let me before we hop off that's gonna be
the end of the tournament
um thank you guys so much everybody who
participated if you're new here make
sure you subscribe to the channel we
will definitely do this again
sounds like we've got we've got a few
people wanting Duos next time so running
some Duos might be fun
I was about to do it tonight I had no
idea it's already like 10 15 though so
uh I can't go into the night with
tonight's dream can't do it can't do it
let me go to Social Club
is that the Dr the deck you've been
running all night dude no it's not
because I spectated you earlier I don't
think you're running that deck earlier
but yeah hats off to all the competition
all the people who participated all dude
we have one spot open in our social club
hey just saying anybody watching right
now if you're on the
uh in the North American servers we have
one spot open oh wait but we we've got
13 requests
see if I know any of these people
I don't know any of these people
I don't know I don't know who to accept
I don't know who to accept everybody's
requesting us
you ran four different decks nice
you haven't played much solos but it was
fun yeah it's solos is mostly what I
play although I finally did hit um
I finally hit Grand Master on the duo
side as well oh my gosh you guys I'm
sorry my contribution is down for the
I'm at 45 yikes
I just don't feel like there's is there
any point in doing
social club stuff right now
all right let's see details
where do I go Drake go to change that
you said it was uh some sort of setting
about
region oh here we go turning on the
geolocation
um manual
North America
United States
I don't have to pick a state do I
because I mean we're all in we're all in
different states
should I just say hide on the state
hey no problem Woody thank you for
joining nice well played in your uh
tournament yeah we have to get some
games sometime for sure
oh dude you're in you're in freaking
Azkaban the the people that were number
one that's awesome
60 more points and your plant is done
yeah I gotta work on the plant for sure
Twigs I can't join right now oh wait is
Twigs about to do
okay here I'm gonna confirm this
and then I'm gonna join twigs and let's
I need to get my Social my uh
Social Club points out
let me run let me run my Hermione
get whiz-bang on there
oh are you in here too Jenny let's go I
have no idea what it is right now I
think it's still that Dragon right
yeah I could see you'd been doing them
Draco
I know they need to bring back the
social club rankings like they're gone
right now right they're not doing
anything with the rankings
or else I would be like I don't feel
like there's a point right now
I mean you do get I guess you do get
these
these Rewards
but we're at that point where like why
isn't all of this stuff reset
I don't understand why it has they're
still in first Jake because I don't
think they've I don't think anything has
been reset like since
since the first week of the game
oh my goodness I can't what is happening
right now
it's like sometimes the dragon does that
and sometimes he doesn't
now we all
run back up
oh we're gonna finish him off let's do
it
only 576
000 damage can we do it
oh
this isn't what the book says
oh yeah augmenti that's a good one Damia
let's get another whiz bang going
oh that's a good protego
the rankings couldn't hold the
awesomeness yeah well they had rankings
like when the game first came out
no I didn't know he did that again
oh my gosh
oh my gosh I've never done this before
what the heck
that was a really bad time to Cassandra
that's for sure
uh Jake I guess it depends on if they've
if they I haven't done my second one but
they're probably gonna do their second
one right after this too
come on a pug no
I love how we have so many power-ups we
can just
you could basically just sit here and
and tank everything
all right 36 seconds
dude we've done a lot of damage though
look at this
10 seconds
Draco have you heard anything about when
they're gonna like reset it or anything
oh my gosh we did a ton of damage
nice
this version of The Forbidden Forest is
wild there's dragons Thunderbirds class
5 Deadly beasts like the nundu yeah yeah
it is pretty intense
but I think the forest aside from the uh
the Ford Anglia change I think the
forest is like all good changes in my
opinion
like I love how many
you can just get legendary Echoes like
crazy now
just something you couldn't do before
all right it's like should we even go up
there I mean I guess we should right
we could do a little bit of damage
can I get a whiz-bang in
no
no Jenny
come on come on walk back up there
I don't know why sometimes I just put I
put nebulous down here
not heard anything about the team Quest
yeah that's why I haven't really been
really doing doing anything with it
right now
I've still been hopping it occasionally
to do the club Adventure just because to
get those rewards right there
this is so crazy
with how many upgrades we have how you
can just
you just tank everything
I've even done do you always do it solo
Draco or do you uh
always jump in with somebody
because honestly with all the upgrades
I've even done it solo before and it's
not
not too crazy
okay wait I'm not gonna use Cassandra
this time because he's about to
he's about to send us flying backwards
oh dude I think we're gonna beat it this
time
wait is he not gonna
is he not gonna send us back this time
all right I'm playing Cassandra
maybe we heard him too much oh you've
always been solo that's crazy
I like how even when you're solo it will
it will like
no no I was talking about this Draco
yeah yeah
we got him let's go
ggs
well played well played
I will claim like see there's no point
of even having these these things right
now
I guess we've unlocked every Club
ability
oh yeah and Jake I don't know if you're
still here I will show you uh
wait where was it you even went to see
oh my gosh I'm still trying to figure
out all the controls
new event Loyalty Rewards
oh yeah it was right here this is where
you used to go to be able to see your
so Jake if you're still watching here's
where you go to to get the
the plant thing you go to season right
here
and then you go to grow Holly with your
roommates we've got five days left
and we've got a lot of work to do
see here's what I don't understand about
the plant you guys earlier we had this
all the way up to 150.
so like I gotta do this one you have to
do dances for this one right
oh
I'm just I'm over the dances
like is this progressing me when I do
this
I'm 47.
I should probably save that last one
right
Brook's like here let's dance
you can also look at it in your dorm
room click on the plant oh nice
I hope they don't reset the currency oh
my gosh
surely they wouldn't reset all your
currency
at least give you a warning
yeah we gotta we gotta get it all right
let's we'll do this dance you have to
get it to progress far enough at the
bottom there Jake so that we get all the
rewards
just don't pick a difficult one Brooke
because I I'm on PC
oh man
oh yeah I know you can dance with
companion I just still you actually did
you know this Woody eggplant you don't
even have to do anything you can
literally just let it play
I tried that the other day
you don't have to push a single thing
what the heck we have been done since
last night
I have no idea what you're talking about
oh wait I can actually
if you don't do at least three people in
your dorm it will be hard
we had we have four yeah see look you
don't even have to push anything
wait Brooke Brooke left to eat wait do
you not even have to stay can you just
leave
look we're still getting points
you like overachieving no not you no
I don't believe I don't believe that at
all
oh man
I wish you could just like back out
assistant
yeah it
affects your partner if they want to get
a higher level Brooke already left
though she backed out
oh it said she left
[Music]
plant for us all the rewards done
nothing but battles dancing in classes
oh have you already completed yours but
you don't did it not give you the
Rewards or something
because I just unlocked the little first
reward earlier
like see how am I earning anything look
at this
and watch it still gives you a c
so if you've ever gotten a uh
see guys and thought oh that wasn't too
bad no
no wait it said Brooke left and she
still got everything what
Brooke how did you
maybe she didn't actually leave
said she left
okay now I'm gonna do it with uh let's
invite like Lottie away she invited me
again
so she didn't leave I feel bad now
all right I'm gonna try to I'm gonna try
to click them this time with the mouse
even though they're really it's really
tough
oh it always says they left but they are
still active
wait so I wonder would I still gonna see
I wonder if both
oh you picked level four oh my gosh
this is gonna be really bad
it also doesn't help that the cursor on
this emulator is orange
oh my gosh
see I can't even I can't even see where
I'm clicking to keep up
I gotta make sure I get the easy ones
I'm almost just like guessing where the
the mouse is
so you see how when they explode
oh I was just a little bit off on that
one
foreign
oh my gosh this would be like good aim
training if you're a fan of first-person
games
this is hurting my finger actually
now this is the one where it's just
impossible
I need two mice
somebody's gonna drop into the stream
right now and be like what you said this
was a dueling the stream title says this
is a dueling tournament
you guys are just dancing what
you can go back rewind but you've only
been doing this for a few minutes oh
wait boom
got it
on the PC client can you can use yeah I
heard it's different on the official yo
we got a C plus let's go
DM me about a turn a tournament video
what's the tournament video
I thought you did it on purpose Brooke
it's all good it was kind of funny
actually
all right now I'm gonna go back to my my
plant
let's see where are you
dude I need to get the obscurus from uh
Twigs are you Gryffindor male
okay now I'm gonna give you some growth
oh that gave 12 actually
plus five an hour oh so this I guess
this is what
see I was thinking every time you put
something in here you should see this
move but I think this bar only moves
with the plant I don't know
I don't know
try the dorm room I feel like that I
feel like this weighs faster actually
oh well unless you're already in here
unless you're literally already in here
all your Hufflepuff gotcha yeah see plus
five per hour
oh it's over here dormitory Co-op
yeah we do have an open spot if
anybody's on opal eye Gryffindor playing
regularly
he joined a dorm of Azkaban players two
weeks before being allowed to join the
Azkaban
I don't get it
I don't get what you're saying
like you didn't realize it or something
you didn't know it was Azkaban players
when you throw keys
when you throw keys at the obscurus when
you get to 46 through 50 use your keys
one by one oh true yeah yeah yeah good
point good point
all right guys I think that's gonna be
it
um this has been a blast a really fun
stream we're gonna have to do this again
that was a lot of fun doing the
tournament eventually I want to actually
do one of the tournaments where
I might actually sponsor or where you
like pay money to give away the Rewards
for the winner
but is 16 the max for that
oh man if we actually do that I feel
like we'd have to do
I'd want to do like sign ups or
something
tryouts
and I I thought hold on I'm gonna go
back I'm not actually starting I'm not
gonna start another one
but
why is that still live
I thought there was a way that you could
do double elimination
did they take that out
or is it only in
dude I'm almost positive
that was an option
32 of you right right if you do teams
oh you're with them before even knowing
about it that that is kind of crazy
crazy
like I don't get the big deal about
Azkaban though witty you gotta explain
this to me like I mean I know they were
at the top of the rankings but are these
like are these famous people or
something
are they just people are they whales who
played the game since soft launch like
give me give me a little background here
I know they were top of the of the uh
Social Clubs
or near the top there
dude I thought there was a double
elimination
yeah Draco glad you were here it was a
blast
you can also do a stream Champions get
an invite to join the room yeah I think
you I think we'd have to do something to
make it to where
to where uh wait create League I thought
is that a separate option because I made
a video on this you guys and in that
video
I'm almost positive there was another
option here
maybe you had to put something in first
okay wait if we lock it
I don't know dude I don't know I just
maybe I uh
I must just be misremembering
I must be misremembering
oh there's still two people in there
spectating
we're done guys sorry
and I wish they would add an option to
let you like in the room I don't like
that you can't in the room
the group of tryhards that want nothing
but the best some are whales some are
just overly oh gosh okay
I was like
the way you're talking it's like it's
like um
you ever heard of the skull Society
it's this uh this sounds like some
secret organization I gotta do they let
me into Asco
oh
man so funny
giant stranger giant stranger join house
rack and tour my friends
some up-and-comers rising up through the
ranks who barely knew anything about the
game
and we're in the top
what were we in Draco we were in the top
30. I know top like top top 100 for sure
just you you just wait
the house rack and tour is Gonna Keep
Rising
It's Gonna Keep Rising stranger we got
one open spot right now stranger
we got one open spot 39 okay see there
you go top 40.
top 40.
remember when he got banned from
chatting industry but I do not remember
that
24 hours stream one time dude
all right right here right here is being
as we end off
stranger I've been thinking about doing
a
trying to play every Harry Potter game
ever made in one 24-hour stream
tell me that wouldn't be a banger
YouTube video
I played every Harry Potter game in 24
hours
dude I feel like that's a million plus
video way to happen
and I would live stream it every every
yes dude the mobile the uh not the
mobile not the mobile
imagine I'm like trying to find old
Nokia phones to play no but the handheld
game like all the handheld the console
if you haven't seen my video stranger
I went on a quest to buy every Harry
Potter video game
and well whether or not I succeeded you
gotta go watch the video you gotta watch
the video right here on YouTube guys
thank you so much this has been awesome
I hope you all have a fantastic rest of
your week as always thank you all so
much for watching
and I will talk to you again soon not
beat them JP just play them so I was
thinking like a 30 half an hour
half an hour for each game
and it could be done it could be done
all right guys later have a good one